merci d'être avec nous verra vous
habitez à Kiev vous êtes professeur de
français tout d'abord pouvez-vous nous
expliquer comment s'est passé cette nuit
donc chez nous là où j'habite tout était
bien tout est calme pas contre hier on a
aussi les missile à la tour de
télévision mais pour l'instant nous
avons la télé et il y a les quartiers
qui était bombardé cette nuit et donc à
côté de Killian
les soldats Ukrainiens ils font ils font
tout leur possible pour garder la ville
parce que de tous les côtés les troupes
on essaie de prendre la capitale mais
pour l'instant nous avons vraiment la
force qui nous garde et justement quelle
est la situation ce matin nous sommes au
7e jour de guerre on sait que la ville
de Carson est tombée entre les mains de
Moscou c'est ce qu'affirme l'armée russe
quel est votre sentiment ce matin à
l'offensive qui se prépare
hier j'ai reçu l'information de
calcul là dit une dame qui fait d'abord
kiki
Daniel est revenue après la guerre les
réunion à donner
complètement détruite vraiment mais il y
a un morceau
de ville où les gens continuent à se
défendre elle elle a organisée le cerf
pour produire les tomates les bons les
légumes et elle dit hier elle m'a dit
que je viens chaque jour pour ramasser
pour faire les récolter pour donner tout
ça au soldat aux hôpitaux aux orphelin
le problème que c'est maintenant c'est
pas la guerre avec les arbres régulières
c'est la guerre avec les populations
civile donc on perd beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui les vieux les femmes les les
enfants ça c'est horrible
vous avez justement des proches qui sont
partis au combat vous avez des amis
peut-être oui
nos amis
chasseur et beaucoup de ses collègues
sont partis pour vos participer dans le
détachement civil beaucoup de mes élèves
aussi je vois ce que j'ai tous parce que
j'ai passé la nuit dans le sous-sol et
là il y avait l'humidité
à l'étage au-dessus de chez nous il y a
des jeunes qui sont partis au logement
civil pour protéger la ville pourquoi
avez-vous décidé de rester à Kiev vous
êtes à Kiev pourquoi avez-vous décidé de
rester à caisse pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
décidé de quitter la ville vous aussi
vous voulez rester résister
vous êtes de problème si on peut c'est
pas le problème c'est de cause d'abord
j'ai une belle-mère qui a 94 ans et je
peux pas la laisser ici c'est pas
possible
je décharte qui aussi
c'est difficile de voyager avec les
animaux et de la troisième chose que
demain je vais être utile pour défendre
ma ville je fais tout ce que je peux
faire malgré que je suis un peu coincé
mais
célibataire vous êtes professeur de
français Viera grégorenko comment
s'organise les écoles on sait qu'elle
servent de refuge
donc dans chaque école on a fait le
refuge parce que chaque école le
sous-sol on organise la balle l'espèce
de
donc on a mis le tapis de sport on les
mis sur le sol on a préparé on a préparé
le de l'eau de nourriture les gens qui
sont qui habitent autour des écoles
viennent pour se cacher là-bas parce que
plus c'est plus calme en plus c'est plus
possible dans la compagnie que tout seul
enfermé dans un appartement merci
beaucoup Vieira grégorenco d'avoir
témoigner sur notre antenne on vous a
évidemment plein de courage et et encore
une fois vraiment beaucoup de beaucoup
de courage pour ce qui se passe et merci
encore d'avoir témoigner moi je veux
dire une chose merci beaucoup pour tout
tout tous mes amis qui habitent en
France qui nous soutiennent
ça c'est tellement important quand tu
sens
les gens qui pensent à nous qui nous
donne la volonté de défendre notre
Leclerc donc merci beaucoup et merci
encore à vous et encore